situation difficile dans les hôpitaux
cette semaine ce sont les internes chez
les infirmières anesthésistes
ils disent leur mécontentement au
venezuela
la situation redevient normale mais rien
n'est réglé reportage de l'équipe
d'antenne 2 dans ce journal
on n'arrête pas le progrès au salon de
l'agriculture les vaches produisent
maintenant du lait mais aussi autre
chose
le ton monte entre pierre villepreux et
albert terrasse l'ancien international
est accusé d'avoir conseillé les
vainqueurs en bio bonsoir
mais tout d'abord parlons du temps 21
degrés à paris nous ne sommes que le 6
mars
c'est un record jamais il n'avait fait
si chaud depuis que la météo existe sur
les plages de l'atlantique vers le sud
ouest ou même on se baigner aujourd'hui
et oui partout en france en tout cas on
avait l'impression d'avoir basculé dans
une autre saison et personne ne s'en est
plaint un an j'ai tout de même bien sûr
les avalanches en montagne encore deux
morts et un blessé à tignes précaution
contre les avalanches
emmanuel vanier la neige n'a presque
plus aucun secret pour eux les
spécialistes du centre d'études de la
neige de grenoble ici on épie le moindre
flocon on analyse en permanence l'état
du manteau neigeux lui balise argos et
une centaine d'observateurs transmettent
chaque jour une multitude d'informations
état des différentes couches de neige
vitesse du vent ensoleillement
température
autant d'informations traitées sur
ordinateurs qui permettent d'évaluer
avec précision le risque d'avalanche
deux mètres de neige fraîche sont tombés
la semaine dernière sur les alpes du
nord
le risque d'avalanche est très important
quels conseils vous donne alliés aux
skieurs aujourd'hui et bien aujourd'hui
de ne pas s'écarter des pistes balisées
ne pas faire du hors piste et encore
moins de la randonnée
a grenoble on travaille aussi en chambre
froide sur des échantillons recueillis
en altitude à droite en bas de l'écran
un cristal de la sous couche il est
presque rond il se comporte comme une
bille la neige fraîche tombée la semaine
dernière c'est donc déposé sur un
véritable tapis roulant une cinquantaine
de personnes emportées par des coulées
depuis trois jours à chaque fois des
accidents survenus en hors piste si les
skieurs persiste à ne pas écouter les
conseils des spécialistes s'attendent à
de nouveaux accidents mortels
la santé ne va pas bien c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire la semaine dernière la
situation paraissait débloquer avec les
crédits accordés aux médecins mais cette
semaine d'autres professions manifestent
leur colère
les internes menace toujours de cesser
le travail mercredi et jeudi
les infirmières anesthésistes de leur
côté ont poursuivi leur grève commencée
hier leurs représentants ont été reçus
tout à l'heure à l'hôtel matignon
auparavant vous le voyez sur ces images
300 personnes avaient manifesté dans les
rues de paris
le mini de la santé claude evin a tenu
des propos très fermes tout à l'heure à
l'égard de ces deux catégories
professionnelles il les a invités à
modérer leur revendication
rappelant que d'autres professions
hospitalière avait aussi des problèmes
alors que se passe-t-il dans nos
hôpitaux et bien voici un exemple celui
de l'hôpital de niort c'est ce qu'on
appelle un hôpital général laniel ville
où plus de 2000 salariés tous mobilisés
pour défendre leur hôpital l'hôpital
général de niort le premier employeur du
département des deux sèvres un hôpital
en crise comme la plupart des hôpitaux
généraux en france
et quelle crise cris des salaires crise
du matériel crise du recrutement crise
du logement
le tout sur fond de crise financière et
budgétaire on peut se demander quelle
entreprise privée pourrait se relever
d'une telle situation en cause c'est
premièrement et de loin les salaires le
salaire des infirmières mais aussi celui
des médecins de plus en plus des motivés
pour une carrière auquel ils croient de
moins en moins exemple ce jeune
cardiologue de 33 ans après 14 ans 15
ans d'études
le salaire d'un praticien hospitalier en
début de carrière et de douze mille
francs par mois alors que dans une
pratique libérale le salaire ou le
revenu mensuel est beaucoup plus
important donc au moins 50% supérieur à
ce salaire en cause c'est aussi le
matériel
il est de plus en plus vieux car faute
de moyens financiers ne peut être
remplacé au rythme des progrès
technologiques exemple ce service de
radiologie est essentielle pour le
diagnostic
nous avons une dizaine de salles de
radiologie et à l'heure actuelle il ya
une des salles qui arrive à vétusté qui
arrive à avoir une vingtaine d'années et
on ne trouve plus de pièces de
remplacement la crise de l'hôpital c'est
aussi le manque cruel de médecins en
france
2700 postes sont actuellement vacants à
niort
on recherche depuis deux ans deux
gynécologues et un cardiologue depuis
trois ans un radiologue depuis cinq ans
un chirurgien orthopédiste
sans parler des médecins qui ne reste
que quelques mois avant d'aller
travailler dans le privé
exemple le service de réanimation depuis
six ans que le service est ouvert on sur
un poste de réanimation on a eu trois 3
médecins différents et le troisième
médecin qui occupe le poste maintenant
décidé de partir en milieu d'année et ce
n'est pas tout la crise de l'hôpital
c'est aussi la vétusté des locaux car
bien souvent à côté du nouveau bâtiment
flambant neuf existe l'ancien à niort il
est réservé comme par hasard aux malades
mentaux une image suffisante pour faire
comprendre au delà des mots qu'il ya
vraiment quelque chose a changé dans
l'hôpital d'aujourd'hui
une nouvelle collision ferroviaire en
grande bretagne c'est la deuxième
catastrophe en moins de 48 heures cette
fois cela s'est passé en écosse à
glasgow il y a deux morts et plus de 40
blessés
michel perron
ce sauveteur va tenter de mettre sous
perfusion le conducteur du train
prisonnier des tôles froissées
il ne sera finalement dégagé qu'au bout
de plusieurs heures d'efforts le
conducteur de l'autre convoi lui a été
tué sur le coup
de même qu'un voyageur une cinquantaine
de passagers ont été blessés la plupart
ne souffre que le coupures et contusions
légères
la collision a eu lieu à quelques
kilomètres glasgow alors que deux petits
trains de banlieue circulait en sens
opposés sur la même voie on en ignore
encore les causes mais 48 heures après
l'accident le relais et syndicats de
cheminots
le parti travailliste ne ménagent pas
leurs critiques de la gestion de british
à elle accusée de sacrifier la sécurité
à la rentabilité
l'homme d'affaires libanais roger tamraz
at il été enlevés les dépêches sont
contradictoires ce soir mais il semble
bien que tu as mraz l'un des hommes
impliqués dans la sphère pechiney à
paris il semble bien que ce financier et
été enlevés au liban
il était aussi il faut le dire au coeur
d'affaires financières dans ce pays
hervé brusini fils d'homme d'affaires et
homme d'affaires lui même ancien de
cambridge d'harvard devenu l'un des tous
premiers financier de son pays
voici roger tamraz une irrésistible
ascension qui semble à présent quelque
peu compromise lampy entamera ce nommé
al mashreq la deuxième banque libanaise
elle est à présent en fuite un trou
évalué à 800 millions de dollars
amine gemayel l'ami de table rase n'est
plus président est garanti se sont
réduites comme peau de chagrin
il a fallu tout liquider y compris en
suisse et à paris
à paris où la banque de participation et
de placement est l'une des filiales de
table rase cette v pay pay est elle
aussi maintenant liquidation table rase
la bpp de noms qui ont été cités dans
l'affairé chine et la banque parisienne
du financier libanais seraient
intervenus dans l'achat de quinze mille
titres frauduleux
roger tamraz avait fini par s'enfuir ils
vivaient ici à l'hôtel soho merlande à
l'ouest de beyrouth sous protection de
ruz antenne 2 l'avait rencontrée il y a
quelques semaines
écoutez le
étonnant qui font du bruit parce que les
banques se retrouvent dans toutes les
régions du liban à elle ne savait que
vous pouvez pas mettre des frontières à
ce qu'on appelle le capitole les
capitaux telle est bien la question les
forces libanaises accuse table rase de
leur avoir volé 200 millions de dollars
vient des petits actionnaires se
plaignent d'avoir été floués enlevé où
nous rançonner hop à angers table rase
intéresse beaucoup de monde à beyrouth
le venezuela normalisée c'est ce qu'a
affirmé ce matin le président carlos
andres perez la situation est normale at
il dit et l'ordre a été rétabli
pourtant rien n'est réglé dans ce pays
car les problèmes économiques restent
entiers après les émeutes qui ont fait
entre 250 et 500 morts notre envoyé
spécial paul nahon est à caracas
voici son reportage dimanche matin
devant la morgue centrale de caracas
caracas qui n'en finit plus d'enterrer
ses morts l'explosion de violence a été
soudaine et terrible l'armée a réprimé
dans un bain de sang dans cette salle
des centaines de cadavres qui n'ont pas
encore été identifiés
l'une de ces jeunes femmes vient d'aller
reconnaître le corps de son mari l'autre
cherche toujours son fils disparu depuis
plus de quatre jours
moi j'ai perdu ma fille de 10 ans vous
savez la répression était terrible où
j'habite
les soldats sont arrivés ils ont tiré
partout il était comme fou nous on était
terrorisé et surtout désespéré
bilan officiel de ces émeutes donné par
le gouvernement lui-même 350 morts mais
d'après les informations que j'ai pu
recueillir ici ce bilan serait beaucoup
plus lourd plus de 800 morts et 3000
blessés
la ville est toujours quadrillée par les
militaires ces militaires qui ont tiré
au bazooka sur la foule
descendu des quartiers pauvres pour
piller en fait des émeutes de la faim
provoquée par les hausses brutales de
prix imposées par le gouvernement
les denrées de première nécessité pain
les suppôts doubles et doubles et
triples et même les transports publics
et les sens une augmentation
insupportable alors que le salaire moyen
est ici de 600 francs par mois
hier après-midi le général perez lukasz
inspecter les troupes chargées de
maintenir l'ordre dans les quartiers
populaires de la ville des quartiers où
les habitants sont toujours obligés de
faire la queue pour s'approvisionner en
fruits légumes lait et fromage
l'état est là c'est qu'elle a commencé à
5 heures du matin ça se passe plutôt
bien mais ça va continuer jusqu'à 5
heures cet après midi paradoxalement la
population ne manifeste aucune hostilité
envers ses soldats qui ont réprimé si
durement les émeutes mais une armée avec
il faudra désormais compter au venezuela
tous les militaires sont attachés à la
démocratie
cette démocratie nous l'avons défendue
est la défendrons jusqu'à la mort cette
liberté le venezuela on jouit depuis
trente ans un record en amérique latine
mais le pays est miné par l'inflation et
la tête malgré d'immenses richesses
pétrolières
plus de la moitié de la population vit
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté dans ces
quartiers qui encerclent la ville
je ne pense pas que la démocratie est
mise en jeu mais c'est un avertissement
très sérieux pour que les changements
qui doivent faire parvenir maintenant se
fasse avec un équilibre des coûts de
toute partie du jeu de la société
vénézuélienne de son palais le président
carlos andres perez a reconnu les
erreurs de son gouvernement
nous sommes tous coupables at il affirmé
mais il a lancé un cri d'alarmé aux pays
riches
attention at il dit si les états unis et
l'europe ne révise pas leurs rapports
économiques avec nous pays pauvres la
situation exposera à nouveau en amérique
du sud dans ces pays d'amérique latine
le problème principal est en général la
répartition de la richesse les riches
sont riches les pauvres sont très
pauvres
c'est le cas aussi en equateur c'est ce
que vous verrez ce soir dans l'émission
blanche et noire présentée par jean
marie cavada à 20h30 aussitôt après le
journal une émission consacrée à
l'action humanitaire
un exemple l'action de la lcf en
équateur auprès des indiens quechua ces
indiens vivent dans un dénuement total
reportage bruno le dress patrick voix
efforts intenses souffle court
tant pis pour l'exotisme mais à plus de
5000 mètres sur la cordillère des andes
les indiens aussi souffrent même si le
travail se déroule avec accompagnement
musical
il s'offre pour la vie pour l'eau pure
qu'ils vont chercher là haut
des kilomètres de tranchées pour amener
l'eau village un travail éprouvant animé
par le chef de mission de l'action
internationale contre la faim en
equateur
l'argent qui permet d'acheter le
matériel arrive de france les indiens
fournissent la main d'oeuvre
tu vois pas ce que moi je pense qu'ils
les travaux il faut progresser faut
travailler dur c'est pas toi comme ça
doucement pour travailler ici ils ont
travaillé les femmes les hommes les
enfants tout le monde mais quand je vois
que les travaux le travail le travail
pas comme on dit ça fait bien alors là
on sourit on se met au bras on voit la
cha rumba tout ça doit mais après que
les choses se passent ou précieuses en
altitude hausse en valeur dans la vallée
là où dominent les haciendas les grandes
propriétés à l'herbe bien verte et
grasse le domaine naturel des indiens se
trouvait ici on les a refoulé là haut où
la terre trop pauvre offre à peine de
quoi vivre
membre de l'opep l'équateur est un pays
riche
ces indiens survivent comme ils peuvent
carence en vitamine manque d'hygiène
alcoolisme chronique
ils meurent trop vite trop jeune trop
tôt près d'un enfant sur deux net 1 bat
l'âge adulte
ouverture de la conférence de vienne ce
matin et déjà monsieur chez vernazza le
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères a proposé un nouveau plan
pour la réduction des forces armées en
europe à vienne pour les 35 participants
il s'agit en effet de rééquilibrer l'est
et l'ouest en matière d'armement mais on
ne devrait pas y parler des armes
nucléaires seulement des armes
conventionnelles
georges bortoli
ambiance typiquement viennoise un palais
un fiacre et un café viennois plus
exactement café c'est af eux les
initiales anglaises de forces armées
conventionnelles en europe
l'enjeu de cette conférence qui se
déroule à la hofburg l'ancien palais des
empereurs d'autriche et qui réunit 35
pays 33 pays européens plus les états
unis et le canada
ce sont effectivement les forces
conventionnelles autrement dit non au
nucléaire mais dès ce matin le ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères a
déclaré qu'il faudrait aussi parler
rapidement des armes nucléaires à courte
portée sur quoi il ne facilite pas les
choses car avant de sacrifier leurs
dernières armes nucléaires existantes en
europe
les américains voudraient que les
soviétiques et le pacte de varsovie
diminue leur supériorité en char en
transports de troupes blindés en
artillerie toutes ses armes beaucoup
plus offensive que des possibles pour
lesquels l'est possède un avantage
manifeste que les soviétiques
reconnaissent d'ailleurs
voilà pour les enjeux georges bortoli
est-ce que l'est et l'ouest à vienne
c'est à dire d'un côté le pacte de
varsovie de l'autre côté l'otan est ce
qu'ils ont des chances de s'entendre
vraiment les soviétiques en tout cas on
fait vous le savez hervé un pas
important en reconnaissant oui nous
avons davantage d'armes dans le centre
de l'europe donc nous devons retirer
davantage
bon cela dit il ya même un commencement
d'exécution puisque moscou annonce que
5300 chars par exemple vont elles
peuvent retirer du centre europe
mais même avec 5300 sharp et moins il
reste quand même les soviétiques à cuba
reçoivent idées restent en position de
lourdes supériorité c'est pourquoi les
occidentaux demandent des réductions
beaucoup plus forte encore mais est-ce
que cet écart dans les armements peut
réellement se réduire
c'est d'abord une question politique
parce que si monsieur gorbatchev retire
beaucoup de troupes d'europe centrale ça
risque de donner des démangeaisons
d'indépendance hongrois ou
tchécoslovaque par exemple qui vont se
dire et les soviétiques s'en vont
profitons-en
mais notre part il faut qu'ils en
retirent suffisamment de ses forces et
de ses armes pour donner un sentiment de
confiance aux occidentaux car sans
sentiment de confiance ils n'auront plus
envie désarmés merci georges le tibet
une nouvelle fois saisi par la violence
le sang a coulé à lhassa à quatre jours
de l'anniversaire du soulèvement c'était
début 88 éric perrin commente ces
affrontements ainsi les principales
informations internationales de ce lundi
deuxième jour de violences au tibet tout
comme l'année dernière plusieurs
milliers de tibétains sont descendus
dans les rues de lhassa la capitale pour
réclamer l'indépendance de leur pays
annexé en 1959 par la chine
les manifestants s'en sont pris aux
magasins chinois érigeant des barricades
les policiers débordés ont tiré sur la
foule il y aurait au moins 15 morts et
plus d'une centaine de blessés
arrestations dans le cadre du scandale
recrute cosmos de l'ancien président du
géant japonais des télécommunications
entity cette affaire de corruption et de
délits d'initiés a déjà provoqué la
démission de trois ministres et
affaiblit la popularité des
conservateurs au pouvoir depuis plus de
40 ans les inculpations ne font que
commencer
ce scandale politique et économique
pourrait être aussi important que celui
de la sphère lookheed en 1973
enterrement à bogota de josé antequera
le dirigeant communiste assassiné
vendredi dernier devant la montée des
attentats la classe politique
colombienne réclame une réaction plus
énergique de gouvernement la gauche
principalement visés exige l'élimination
des auteurs de ces actes terroristes des
groupes paramilitaires financé en grande
partie par l'argent de la drogue
en attendant elle a décidé de suspendre
sa participation au dialogue pour la
plaie avec la guérilla en france
dernières nouvelles des municipales les
verts montent au front
les écologistes présentent en effet 7500
candidat dans toute la france au total
des listes dans 148 villes de plus de
3500 habitants à paris les verts seront
présents dans vingt quatre
arrondissements pardon ce soir un coup
de projecteur sur strasbourg la capitale
européenne saisie par le doute marcel
rudloff le candidat rpr udf qui est le
maire sortant aussi n'est pas certain de
retrouver son siège
il est attaqué sur sa gauche par la
rocardienne catherine trautmann et sur
sa droite par trois listes dont celle du
front national jean michel mercurol il
barbe
reportage
orchestre symphonique dans la toute
nouvelle salle des congrès de strasbourg
marcel rudloff cds sénateur maire
sortant se veut loin du tumulte
électorale élu confortablement au
premier tour en 83 il se contente de
l'acquis de six ans de mandat
d'abord une audience à l'ambassadeur du
rss prestige international de la ville
oblige la visite ensuite d'un chantier
de maisons des jeunes et de la culture
dans un quartier le bol de soupe aide à
soigner la popularité
pourtant la gestion rudloff dans son
propre camp ne fait pas l'unanimité
l'ancien ministre andré bord en rupture
de rpr et le barriste michel stourm lui
disputent les voix udf rpr
de plus il lui faut compter avec la
percée du front national 20 % pour le
pen aux dernières présidentielles
le plus grand reproche c'est d'avoir
manqué de dynamisme d'esprit de décision
et de volonté pour défendre les grands
dossiers de strasbourg nous avons perdu
le synchrotron nous avons perdu l'office
des marques nous sommes en train de
perdre le parlement européen
tout ça ça fait beaucoup des chefs des
critiques au maire sortant amplement
partagée par ses autres adversaires de
droite comme de gauche même si le gros
des arguments du front porte plutôt sur
l'immigration ici ce sont les verts les
plus assidus à contrer le fn sur les
marchés les verts dont le crédit
progresse et qui espère aussi être
présent au second tour pour arbitrer le
duel rudloff trautmann catherine
trautmann 38 ans éphémère ministre du
premier gouvernement rocard peut
incarner un dynamisme retrouvé de
strasbourg après une longue querelle de
préséance entre socialistes elle croit
maintenant en ses chances pour défendre
et porter haut à l'unisson des volontés
de paris les couleurs européennes de
strasbourg
tous les pronostics comme vous le dites
peuvent donner à partir des chiffres
antérieurs
marcel rudloff gagnant mais il n'a pas
gagné je puis vous le dire et si cette
campagne a l'air un peu terne
je dirais simplement qu'il faut se
méfier des eaux dormantes pense beaucoup
de bien madame trautmann mais je ne
voudrais pas qu'elle soit maire de
strasbourg n'est jamais sûr d'être réélu
mais j'ai très très forte conviction
dans le succès de ma liste
les communistes qui n'ont pas eu leur
place sur la liste de l'ingénerie
gardiennes ont dû s'allier avec le
émergé en tout cette liste à l'assaut de
strasbourg prospère mais morose aux
strasbourgeois maintenant de dire qui
répondra le mieux à leur but commun le
plus cher élever leur ville au rang de
capitale incontestée de l'europe
les sept semaines dans télématin pour
les 4 vérités j'ai rarement un continue
de recevoir les principaux leaders
politiques après jean marie le pen
c'était ce matin
eh bien demain matin à 7 heures 45 ce
sera pierre joxe toujours la grève dans
le nettoyage du métro parisien mais la
situation semblait toutefois s'apaiser
puisque les négociations ne sont pas
rompues
elles reprendront demain les grévistes
de la comatex négocié avec la direction
sous l'égide du médiateur nommé par le
ministre du travail à paris l'événement
du début mars et le salon de
l'agriculture
ce soir nous allons voir les progrès
techniques dans ce domaine ils sont
immenses et ça va vite
ces dernières années on savait par
exemple faire des veaux complètement
identique pour une bonne qualité de
viande
maintenant grâce aux manipulations
génétiques ont fait mieux
les vaches peuvent fabriquer un les
améliorer avec en plus des substances
pharmaceutiques
voyez ce reportage de marc yves mano et
jean-françois bernigaud
dans le bestiaire du salon les souris
ont fait leur apparition où elle se
taille un franc succès on envoie chez
nous les ferons pas
voyez les mêmes ce ne sont pas des rats
des champs les des souris de laboratoire
grâce à ces petites bêtes de grosses
vaches vont améliorer très vite leur
potentiel en sautant plusieurs
générations entre les vaches à 2000
litres de lait des années 50 et celle à
10000 d'aujourd'hui il aura fallu trente
ans 2 sélections par croisements
successifs des meilleure laitière avec
les meilleurs taureaux désormais dans
les laboratoires de l'inra ont sous
toutes les étapes et on n'hésite pas à
faire des mélanges apparemment contre
nature ici on injecte dans un embryon de
souris
le gène des protéines du lait de vache
ce gène elle va le transmettre à sa
descendance directe appliqué à la vache
c'est technique permet de modifier la
qualité du lait ou de faire produire par
l'animal des substances nouvelles
or le montre l'exemple de la souris du
génie que nous avons derrière nous
c'est la possibilité de faire produire
un animal une substance qui ne produit
pas normalement dans son lait donc
produire en grande quantité par ailleurs
d'une substance de très grande valeur à
utilisation pharmaceutique médicales
difficiles à produire autrement
pour les chercheurs il n'est pas loin le
temps où la vache se transformera en
armoires à pharmacie quatre ou cinq ans
maximum au salon elle ne se doute de
rien mais les éleveurs eux ils pensent
de plus en plus l'agriculteur
change-t-il de statut en fait vous
milliers non il va rester agriculteurs
qui va nourrir la nation c'est vrai mais
il va aussi avoir un statut de
fournisseur de matières premières pour
d'autres professions
une chose est sûre dans cette affaire
les taureaux n'y sont pour rien la cure
de jouvence du docteur raz baby ce
médecin est un charlatan il avait ouvert
une clinique dans la haute-vienne pour
rajeunir les patients recevaient des
injections de cellules fraîche venant de
testicules de mouton par exemple cela se
pratique à l'étranger notamment en
suisse mais en france c'est tout à fait
illégal et la police a fermé
l'établissement claude crespo derrière
les murs du manoir de mon bas on venait
retrouver une seconde jeunesse
mais la technique du docteur à baby
traiter aussi l'asthme la cellulite les
ulcères et même le mongolisme sa méthode
des injections de cellules vivantes à
partir de foetus de moutons les bêtes
étaient abattus dans une pièce du
château
cette pratique est légale en suisse mais
elle ne l'est pas chez nous doute plane
du conseil de l'ordre de la haute vienne
sont pas des pratiques nouvelles ou
chongqing sont les pratiques donc
ancienne on sait qu'elles sont vraiment
totalement inefficace mais quelle
abusent de la crédulité des gens et on
sait également qu elles peuvent être
tout à fait dangereux alors on ne peut
pas dans un cadre de la santé publique
laissez ce type de pratique se faire
d'autant plus que ça correspond
également à des pratiques de
charlatanisme pure et simple avec un
un intérêt financier qui est absolument
scandale depuis trois ans 500 curistes
sont venus ici déboursant entre dix et
vingt mille francs pour quatre jours de
traitement
les 21 derniers patients ont été
renvoyés chez eux la clinique miracle
est fermé et le praticien inculpé par le
juge la fontaine d'exercice illégal de
la médecine
ça va mal dans le rugby français non
seulement le quinze de france a été
battue samedi par les anglais mais en
plus les dirigeants commencent à se
déchirer alors à ma gauche pierre
villepreux ancien international
soupçonnée d'avoir conseillé l'ennemi
héréditaire c'est-à-dire l'anglais et à
ma droite albert ferrasse président tout
puissant de la fédération pour l'instant
c'est seulement un round d'observation
mais le ton monte jean manière ils
peuvent venir funk la grande faune la
voici
pierre villepreux l'ancien arrière de
quinze de france prodigue en stage et en
anglais ses conseils à l'équipe
d'angleterre une équipe moribonde depuis
1980 mais qui à cet été dominé
l'australie et pire samedi bas la france
à twickenham pour la première fois
depuis dix ans c'est la boucle de thé
qui fait déborder la taxe
honni soit qui mal y pense ville
produite en traître le professeur
honoris causa se fait traiter de cantona
du rugby et de journalistes bidon pour
quelques piges à libération menacé
d'exclusion il répond là n'est pas la
question
to open your eyes
cette dernière collaboration on en parle
beaucoup et je crois pourtant que le
rugby français a d'autres choses à
penser
et les problèmes de fond qui existait
bien on les évoque pas alors on se bat
et ça vole au ras des pâquerettes
oui mais voilà c'est que le président
ferrasse n'aime pas trinquer surtout à
la santé les anglais même s'il reconnaît
que villepreux n'est en rien à l'origine
de ce mauvais samedi
pour lui la france est son équipe c'est
l'union sacrée
il ne doit pas y avoir de brebis égarées
mais pourquoi me dirigeais aucun joueur
ne peut faire une émission télévisée
cris avant les journaux ont participé à
quoi que ce soit ça l'autorisation ou du
comité régional de la fédération horwill
preuve ça soit sur le règlement il fait
ce qu'il a envie de faire ça rien
demandé à personne car je peux dire que
ça durera pas pour si longtemps que ça
dure et c'est pas prêt demain parce que
si on va fermer les yeux c'est de là bas
on va apprendre les ouvrir est il
acceptable qu'au plan sportif existe
encore des interdits nationaliste une
question à laquelle monsieur ben buts
devra répondre prochainement
mais décidément l'europe même sportive
n'est pas encore sorti du tunnel
s'ajoute un résultat de ce sport fait
paris-nice cycliste bien sûr la première
étape courue entre gien et moulin a été
gagnée au sprint par le belge etienne de
wild au classement général c'est le
français thierry marie qui est en tête
lavilliers au zénith fait en ce moment à
paris avant une longue tournée dans
toute la france c'est le retour de saint
nanar ou de la ville au au choix cette
fois il a bourlingué et il le raconte
gérard dalmat assister aux répétitions
cet enjeu
la planète à force de la sillonner il
aboie de haut
bernard la vie pour cet ancien boxeur la
vie est un coup de poing le spectacle
est un ring au milieu du public c'est
donc là billets qui a voulu cette
nouvelle scène prolonger vers les gens
j'ai eu un choc esthétique quoi et même
émotionnel parce que cette scène elles
portent vers les gens
légende les haines c'est quand mes
chansons que j'aime j'aime pas une
chanson alors je vais pas commencer à
des parties cachées derrière nous
casseurs du paysage souvent terme du
showbiz français l'habiller est plus que
jamais l'auteur engagé exemple pour
dénoncer les enfants trop petits avec un
fusil trop grands chanteurs partisans
chanteur reporter tu pourrais pas que si
je pars perdre
je m'emmerde tragédie
une ressource et comme j'ai une sorte de
journaliste musical m'en vais ça me
donne une raison d'exister et après je
me découvre des talents qui avait pas
bon parfois aussi ça se déclenche quand
même quand on décolle
l'idée que je suis un mec qui peut
témoigner au mieux les choses que j'ai
vécues dans un avion ça se fait qu'ils
ont pris cet éternel nomade est de tous
les combats
vous le trouverez toujours sont les
routes de l'injustice le regard allumé
car dit-il tout se voit d'un seul coup
d'oeil
20 de ce journal tout de suite la météo
laurent cabrol malgré sa griffe vous
donnera toutes les précisions sur les
records de chaleur aussitôt après ce
sera le magazine blanche et noire
présentée par jean marie cavada
consacrée à l'aide humanitaire
la dernière édition ce sera vers 00h15
avec philippe gassot à demain 20 heures